permis d'abord chantal hébert michel
sauget bonsoir
ça a fait tiquer quelques personnes
aujourd'hui d'entendre monsieur o'toole
dire cebula envers justin trudeau
n'avait on ne l'avait pas entendu sur ce
terrain là depuis le début de la
campagne chantal hébert ça vous dit quoi
sur la lure de la campagne conservatrice
que l'élan espérer après les débats ne
s'est pas matérialisée et que les
stratèges conservateurs comprime parce
que c'est très très cei que ça va se
jouer en fonction des gens qui vont
décider d'aller voter et ce jeu qu'on
vient d'entendre c'est un appel à la
base qui
rappelez vous que vous l'aimez pas cet
homme-là et s'il vous plaît venez voter
pour moi j'ai surtout à l'est pas voté
pour maxime berreby
mène de rien il monte dans les sondages
michel c'est sur les attaquants gabon il
ya une cuillère d'argent dans la bouche
que vous vous ne vous reconnaissez pas
dans cet homme et moi je suis un homme
la banlieue près du monde et c'est
ça ça veut dire que les choses vont
publier parce que on veut pas faire d'
attaques personnelles sur n'est pas
capable si on n'est pas obligé d'en
faire d'habitude dans une campagne
électorale parce que c'est un couteau à
deux tranchants les attaques
personnelles mais là comme chantal dina
il faut réveiller la base conservatrice
c'est serré et la chance parce qu'il
faut pas oublier le mouvement vers les
conservateurs et ce mouvement là et
arrêtées et maintenant vers les libéraux
dans les sondages fait des gros
mouvements spawn campagne agro mouvement
celle là mais il ya quand même émouvant
vers les libéraux alors pour le seul
moyen pour monsieur autour de gagner
c'est si tôt de sa base se mobilisent et
votée puis effectivement bon bain sous
questions sur maxime bernier justement à
ce que dans un scénario extrêmement
serré comme actuellement il ne vient pas
mêler les cartes dans certains endroits
chantal où vous en êtes dans dans votre
garde envers monsieur bernier la
hockey au québec peut-être dans beauce
mais pas au québec ça c'est clair
peut-être en ontario mais les provinces
où
le bassin de gens qui sont le plus
réfractaire aux mesures sanitaires
sympathique c'est quand même la
saskatchewan l'alberta où les
conservateurs au des votes qui peuvent
se permettre de perdre alors de
sérieusement des échantillonnages sont
tellement petit que je tirerai pas de
conclusion sinon pour dire ces gens là
sont motivés ils ont une cote ce qui est
mieux pour maxime bernier que la
dernière fois michel
et jeux qui disent vouloir voter pour
monsieur pour monsieur bernier méchante
analyse aussi des petits de châtillon
mais ces gens là sont aussi dans les
fait sociologique de jacques yvon le
moins voté alors ce qu'ils vont aller
voter là ils sont très critiqués à cause
de ce zoo sanitaire et ils ont pris
monsieur bernier comme porte parole de
leur frustration là dessus ça c'est une
chose d'autre part sauf sauf la liberté
comme le chantait millions tellement des
grosse majorité
au parti conservateur ça peut faire une
différence en ontario qu'il ya dans
quelques côtés besson albert au soudan
sont durs mais on verra s'ils arrivent à
gagner son pari en bourse ou pas
la dernière fois ça n'avait pas été un
grand succès au vert cette fois ci
bon effet legault on a entendu monsieur
legault en présentation y at il un effet
legault chantal
si un an et on le voit pas dans le sens
où le parti conservateur est à peu près
stable au québec et s'il n'y a pas
d'effets legault c'est probablement
parce qu'un effet débat en anglais et
qui profite pas aux conservateurs que
monsieur legault voudrait beaubois mais
plutôt le québécois et françois blanchet
et le sans rire la personne qui était
modératrice et la présidente du groupe
de sondage angus reid qui vient de
sortir un sondage pour dire à mes yeux
les débats ont surtout profité à et
françois blanchet qui serait selon un
guide suivent à peu près à égalité avec
les libéraux au québec trouvez l'erreur
c'est incroyable c'est pour le savoir
mais ceux qui connaissent un peu ya pire
d'écrire un bon coup la politique se
sont dits las il vient de se mettre un
moteur michel roger le chef du bloc à
son autobus il n'y avait presque pas
rêvé de ça la jeune soir on ne pouvait
pas rêver je ne pouvais pas rêver tir
c'est ce que c'est le genre de chien qui
effectivement sort le vote du bloc
québécois la seule chose qu'il faut se
rappeler par exemple c'est qu'il ya deux
gros groupes de lecteurs au québec et
rouge des bleus est ce qui peut aller
mais pas tout le temps mais ce qui peut
arriver c'est que hangar guerre des voix
le bloc québécois on enlève aux
conservateurs et permet à des libéraux
de passes entre les deux je vous donne
un exemple le président du conseil du
trésor monsieur
je vous lis son nom mé sak i o qui
votent c'est exactement ce qui est
arrivé il ya passé à entre les
conservateurs et le bloc québécois ça ça
peut se reproduire alors ça c'est une
donnée de plus de 2 les prix de
l'imprévisibilité de nous approcher
parce que si on oublie cette question
malheureuse de la modératrice
l'effet legault ses postures qui en est
rien parce que là c'est mélanger le
débat anglais a eu un effet tonique lui
a beaucoup plus fort drôlement sur le
québec que l'appel de monsieur legault
ce que je m'étais chantal et aussi sur
le canada parce que de façon générale on
l'a pas beaucoup regardé et que donc
l'interprétation qu'on en a vu qui était
pas complètement fausses et l'osm en
sentant été celle des françois blanchet
mais d'autre part monsieur legault c'est
quand même collé à erin o'toole et
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ça paye pas
beaucoup
et est ce que ça prenne dommageable chez
sogeti monsieur trudeau par exemple
arrivent à arracher une autre minorité
lundi prochain comment va se retrouver
dans quels rapports de force se retourne
et monsieur legault
moi je note toutes choses c'est que
monsieur lebon fait sa sortie le
lendemain du jour où il y avait eu cette
algarade entre monsieur blanchet et
monsieur trudeau sur savoir qui est à
québécois puis monsieur triaud qui a dit
shota québécois que vous êtes d'affaires
à m'enlever mon droit d'être québécois
il ya un côté pour chez monsieur legault
qui est très important c'est qu'il veut
être capitaine québec il veut être la
personne qui parle des québécois et là
il a entendu trudeau dire non non moi je
parle dans des québécois aussi et sur
toutes sortes de projets où on a besoin
de financement fédéral est adapté je
donne juste le troisième ligne comme
exemple c'est un signal de trudeau qui
dit je prends mes décisions
personnellement là dessus et je ne vais
pas nécessairement référer au
gouvernement du québec ce monsieur
legault dit mme poisson méchante reine
entend organiser la dernière fois qu'il
ya eu deux chefs québécois aura québec
et l'autre sur le bulletin de vote
remontons à 2000 et où jean chrétien qui
se battent pour obtenir un troisième
mandat lucien bouchard qui est premier
ministre s'oppose à la loi sur la clarté
cette élection au moins démontré qu' il
n'y a pas de premier ministre au québec
qui parle pour tout le monde parce que
c'est l'année où jean chrétien eu son
meilleur score au québec d'ailleurs du
schéma on a parlé en démissionne
exactement et ses sacs avec un petit peu
effectivement même si on chante
aujourd'hui c'est le score de cette
élection qui a fait que moi je me suis
dit à court terme moyen terme le rêve la
souveraineté je le met de côté les
québécois ont quand même voté en
majorité en plus réalité pour monsieur
chrétien ça doit vouloir dire quelque
chose très bien rendu qu'on atteint
lundi prochain merci beaucoup à vous
deux très apprécié à l'euro